what's up reject nation we're gonna
watch from the channel shamu
harrison ford in solo a star wars story
deep fake before we go into checking
this video out though i gotta thank
today's video sponsor which is the
ridge wallet ridge let's just shout them
out however we want and i'm so glad they
do
because i really get an opportunity to
come from the hearts
let me just get all the necessary
talking points out of the way sleek and
minimal help you keep stuff organized to
the essentials
fits anywhere rfid blocking
they come in money clip or strap for
cash free shipping and returns
worldwide they got 30 000 5 star reviews
and you can use our code reject nation
to save 10
off on your own wallet i literally
love these wallets i'm not joking just
the other day i saw
a friend of mine who i've known for many
years he's all about fashion and style
he asked if i had a dollar for something
so i pulled out my wallet he
literally went and the juicer's like
whoa is that a ridge wallet
can i see it this guy drives a tesla
and he was impressed with a rich wallet
that's how you know it's good because
then he showed me his wallet and he's
like i feel like a grandpa wouldn't mind
so then he bought a ridge
wallet it sounds like silly but i've
never been in love with something so
materialistic in my entire life and what
better than something that holds and
protects your money
if you want to impress people with
something really sleek
go get yourself a ridge wallet today
www.ridge.com
reject nation
[Music]
wow that looks natural how about you
what are you going to do with your shirt
i thought it was just an empire strikes
back moving for just
a second i didn't realize that that was
i was like oh wait this is from the
this is a deep fake already oh wow
he's searching for his
i don't uh if you said try her family
what's the difference that looks
so real
whoa that looks so real
who doesn't even look like a deep fake
guy this is crazy
what's the difference the difference is
the
empire doesn't send out a team of
enforcers to hunt you down it
really helps that all that error rag is
trying to mirror his facial expressions
too
seriously
maybe i can wow some way to make it up
wow it looks like young harrison ford
it's tripping me out it looks so good
now if only they could got a person to
do the voice
yeah i was going to say he knows me not
you
if you come with me that is
mind-blowingly good if they don't kill
you
you're in this life for good
you find some way to square this
you still get our money damn
[Laughter]
i watched so many deep fakes and this
has got to be one of the best i've ever
seen
holy crap damn did they put on billy d
williams on that one i was wondering it
looked like something was up there and
it didn't 100 look like donald so i
wonder if maybe they did do that yeah
it is billy dee willie i was like i
didn't even notice until
at the split second i was still looking
at harrison ford then you realize like i
guess these guys have just the exact
right head shape
because especially when you watch the
side by side if you're only looking at
harrison ford out of your peripheral
vision it still looks like him
you know oh like it looks like his head
shaped this is like scary
it's weird when they do these side by
sides which
what's tripping me out especially the
first side by side
where it's in the snow and you have
alden eric and then you have harrison
ford
even though harrison ford is the deep
fake it looks like the more natural one
for some reason isn't that
strange maybe yeah i don't know maybe
it's just because we're more used to
seeing him with chewie or maybe they
took a scene that just happened to have
like the perfect lighting that when
applied to this
just made it that much more authentic
looking or something i mean there's
harrison ford's been in the business for
so many years so it's easy to find
footage of him from when he was the age
of alden era right maybe even younger
actually now i think about it because he
popped on the scene with american
graffiti maybe this is pulling from
i don't know how defect technology works
i've tried to
understand it but like i don't get it
i'll just be amazed
for whatever it looks amazing right and
here
this does make you wish they kind of did
something like this
for the movie it's something yeah and
we're getting to a point where we can
you know like this looks better than
de-aging i've seen
this video that they i think it was
shamu who did
the irishman where he did a deep fake
for de niro and pacino and he compared
it with the d
aging and the deep fake on young de niro
looked
better than it did de-aging did on de
niro
yeah um so that video blew my mind
looking at this here if
we're going to be using actors to you
know play
younger versions of themselves at times
i mean this is the way to do it this
isn't even freaking
harrison ford here you know this is all
the terror right all in ararack i know
was coached in a way to try to
capture the way his facial expressions
would kind of move because
he he couldn't do the voice obviously
all their accents nothing like him
um but the facial expressions were the
closest thing they could do with
likeness beyond hair and such i think
that really helps with applying a deep
fake here
that is um you know a testament to other
rights portrayal and just to a certain
extent yeah well now it makes you wonder
too like maybe this will become part of
people's contracts because you have to
imagine that deep fake technology
whatever this
is is also probably related to or maybe
is even the same as a lot of the stuff
that is being used in you know hollywood
cgi and stuff so
in the future now i'm sitting here going
well if you had an actor who just has
the right
physical dimensions you can put any
number of celebrity faces on them and
just cast yeah you could cast people
long after they're dead
it's the same argument as the aging just
in a different corner
well what i'm hoping for that they do
down the road if there's
one deep fake portrayal like a full on d
fake portrayal i'd be in support of
other than an actor playing a younger
version of themselves which i do want to
touch on because i'm sure there's a lot
of people in the comments for this video
who are probably saying
harrison ford should have just done it
and they could have done this but i got
a comment about that in a minute but i'm
hoping for outside of that because
that's the one version i'm like well
that'd be fine like the whole james dean
thing i wasn't a big fan of if they did
that for biopics down the road
that would be the one experiment i would
be more than happy to see if they
actually deep faked the musician's face
or something
onto whoever's playing him i think that
would be excellent and
i would be very curious to see that
however here's the the problem which i
think the irishman
runs into themselves a lot of people
think the way harrison ford moved as
han solo enforcement awakens his
movement
was that of a much older man yes his
body language and the irishman
runs into that problem especially with
de niro doing certain physical movements
when he's supposed to be in his younger
years that even though you have this
wonderful de-aging technology you could
tell by the way his body moves that this
is an older person
and i really think that would have been
the main issue they would have run into
with harrison ford playing you know a
younger han solo
that being set the workaround could have
been
whenever it requires certain physical
scenes you could put a stunt double
there
and yeah just deep fake hairs before
it's based on
him that's the glue that holds the
entire character together at that point
and you could do that i mean like even
on the re-release of terminator 2 the 3d
version
james cameron cg essentially deep faked
schwarzenegger's face onto
the stunt double for a very specific
moment where it was very obvious that it
wasn't arnold schwarzenegger
so you could do the same thing here down
the road
like this is the one arena of deep fake
that i would be very
fascinated to see take place in a movie
i don't know what it is about the
hollywood industry the agent's okay but
d
fake no i don't know what the big deal
is if you're gonna be all supportive dh
why not do some deep fake who cares
it still requires a performance and if
you're and if it's the actor himself
playing that version i think deep fake
technology often looks a lot better than
the aging technology
yeah and i mean you know partly because
you are i guess drawing from a natural
image of somebody's face that hasn't
been you know computer constructed and
there is a definite difference there and
it's funny because yeah i mean they've
made so many strides and now they're
doing you know
de-aging with infrared and stuff like
that yeah just taking
like old footage of somebody's face and
then
you know mapping it and masking it
sometimes is just yeah that much more
effective i wonder what's gonna happen
in the just the future of effects yeah
if they're gonna find
some way of maybe borrowing from this
tech or whatever because
i mean like the one thing that worries
me about deep fake technology more than
de-aging is just you know you could do
this to anybody
um you know and it doesn't have to be in
the guise of a movie or whatever so i
understand the concern
that way these are just incredible when
it comes to these movies especially when
it comes to just
you know showing you what could have
been yeah and yeah i think the point
about the body language is absolutely on
the
on mark just because uh yeah harrison
ford and especially now like i don't
think he would be the type to want to
push himself that hard physically
for a movie like this this would have
been the perfect solo
plus a lord miller yeah completion
do you think they should start going
down the route especially with like
legacy characters
where there's some veteran actors still
around to play younger versions of
themselves with d
fake technology would you have preferred
to see this version of solo
i feel like a lot of people would have
i'm not going to lie i don't think all
the narrow wreck was bad but
i'm very very curious to see a
full-length version
with a harrison ford impersonator that's
the other thing too is you got to get to
a point
where they can find a way to naturally
de-age a voice
too for a lot of these actors you know
there you go
old al pacino sounds very different than
young albuquerque
well and there's also harrison ford who
sounds different yeah and that's a
little more nasally back then and now
he's really down here the quality of
your voice changes and also i gotta
imagine all those cigarettes you gotta
find a way to smooth the voice
out too not just pitch it yeah cause it
gets to a certain point with an actor
at a certain age or it's like well it's
not much you can really do now
yeah before you're just making an
animated character yeah so i'll leave
your thoughts down below last but not
least
lance door so i'm gonna do a little
something
really quick and i'm gonna tell you what
this gift is for you okay
okay so for your wedding
i'm gonna be giving your wife a set of
vr goggles
that allow for deep fake technology now
you can take my face and put it on yours
for a deep fake effect so on your
honeymoon
when she's making love to you with vr
goggles on
she will not see your face but she will
instead see my face
that way she can get the ultimate
wedding present she's been hoping for
this face while she's being made love to
on her honeymoon i mean
it's amazing and by the way if there's
any certain types of companies out there
who are looking
to invest in this idea i think it's
actually a pretty rad idea
and i got certain king couples out there
right i got you one as well so
you can look at her and see my face and
you guys can fulfill your greg and john
love fantasy
or any of our collaborators all the
reject nation is in this program
well lance i hope you're grateful